do you think child support is necessary
in 2022 i don't think child support is
even a thing here in the uk it is okay
well a lot of people don't file for it
in i would say my culture anyway i can
only speak about that yeah you get 18
for one kid of a guy's income but i
don't know anyone that i mean yeah i
don't know anyone that files for it
personally i've had a couple guys come
on because i do public interviews um and
one of them that i did was like my body
my choice his wallet his choice and i
had a bunch of guys sit down and say
they were trapped basically for for a
kid and on the show too yeah
yeah so do you do you guys think that
child support is necessary not really i
do believe that man and woman should
financially support child 50 50. but i
don't think say a man should pay more
okay let's say i agree with that you
agree that we need it or we don't well
i would say it would be unfair to say
the primary uh
keeper of the child would have to pay
100 i think both parents should pay an
equal amount does that mean i agree with
the current ways in which child support
is
put on people no probably not does that
make sense